liebe mitbürgerinnen und liebe mitbürger
was für ein jahr liegt hinter uns
2020 ist etwas über uns gekommen womit
die welt nicht gerechnet hatte
ein bis dahin unbekanntes virus dringt
in unseren körper und unsere leben ein
es trifft uns da wo wir am aller
menschlichsten sind im engen kontakt in
der umarmung im gespräch beim feiern das
virus macht normales verhalten zu einem
risiko und ganz ungewohnte
schutzmaßnahmen normal 2020 dieses jahr
der pandemie war im jahr des lernens wir
mussten im frühjahr auf einen virus
reagieren über dass es kaum gesichertes
wissen und informationen gab
wir mussten entscheidungen treffen von
denen wir zunächst nur hoffen konnten
dass sie sich als richtig erweisen
würden die korona virus pandemie war und
ist eine politische soziale ökonomische
jahrhundertaufgabe
sie ist eine historische krise die allen
viel und manchen zuviel auferlegt hat
ich weiß dass es ungeheures vertrauen
und geduld von ihnen verlangt hat und
weiter verlangt sich auf diesen
historischen kraftakt einzulassen
dafür danke ich ihnen von ganzem herzen
am ende dieses atemlosen jahres heißt es
auch einmal innezuhalten und zu trauern
wir dürfen als gesellschaft nicht
vergessen wie viele einen geliebten
menschen verloren haben ohne ihn in den
letzten stunden nah sein zu können
ich kann ihren schmerz nicht lindern
aber ich denke an sie gerade auch heute
abend
ich kann nur an wie bitter es sich
anfühlen muss für die die wegen corona
um einen geliebten menschen trauern oder
mit den nachwirkungen einer erkrankung
sehr zu kämpfen haben wenn von einigen
unverbesserlichen das virus bestritten
und geleugnet wird
verschwörungstheorien sind nicht nur
unwahr und gefährlich sie sind auch
zynisch und grausam diesen menschen
gegenüber 2020 war bestimmt von sorge
und ungewiss
zugleich war es aber auch ein jahr in
dem so viele über sich hinausgewachsen
sind ohne das an die große glocke zu
hängen
das beweisen uns die ärztinnen ärzte und
pflegekräfte in krankenhäusern
pflegeheimen und anderen einrichtungen
das zeigt sich bei den mitarbeitern der
gesundheitsämter die so plötzlich ins
zentrum des kampfes gegen das virus
gerückt sind
das sehen wir an der einsatzfreude
unserer bundeswehr die an allen ecken
und enden unterstützung leistet
unzählige menschen haben dazu
beigetragen dass unser leben trotz
pandemie weiter möglich war
in den supermärkten und im
gütertransport in den postfilialen in
bussen und bahnen auf den polizeiwachen
in den schulen und kitas in den kirchen
in den redaktionen
ich bin auch immer wieder dankbar dafür
wie diszipliniert die allermeisten
menschen ihre masken tragen wie sie sich
um abstand bemühen
darin drückt sich für mich aus was ein
leben in einer menschenfreundlichen
gesellschaft erst möglich macht
rücksichtnahme auf andere die einsicht
sich selbst auch einmal zurück zu nehmen
das bewusstsein von gemeinsinn diese
haltung von millionen von mitbürgern hat
uns auf unseren bisherigen weg durch die
pandemie manches erspart
sie wird auch im kommenden jahr nötig
seien
was lässt mich hoffen seit wenigen tagen
hat die hoffnung gesichter es sind die
gesichter der ersten geimpft der ganz
alten und ihrer pfleger und pflegerinnen
des medizinischen personals auf den
intensivstationen nicht nur bei uns
sondern in allen europäischen und vielen
anderen ländern
tag täglich werden es mehr schrittweise
werden anderer alters und berufsgruppen
dazu kommen und dann alle die es möchten
auch ich werde mich impfen lassen wenn
ich an der reihe bin hoffen lassen mich
auch die wissenschaftler weltweit aber
gerade auch bei uns in deutschland der
erste verlässliche corona test wurde
hier entwickelt und nun auch der erste
in europa und vielen ländern der welt
zugelassene impfstoff er ist aus der
forschung
weit eines deutschen unternehmens
hervorgegangen und wird jetzt als
deutsch amerikanische produktion
hergestellt
die gründer uhr sahin und slam turnier
aus mainz haben mir erzählt dass
menschen aus 60 nationen in ihrem
unternehmen arbeiten
nichts könnte besser zeigen dass es die
europäische und internationale
zusammenarbeit das ist die kraft der
vielfalt ist die den fortschritt bringt
die aufgaben vor die die pandemie und
stellt bleiben gewaltig bei vielen
gewerbetreibenden arbeitnehmern solo
selbstständigen und künstlern herrschen
unsicherheit ja existenzangst
die bundesregierung hat sie in dieser
ganz unverschuldeten notlagen nicht
alleingelassen staatliche unterstützung
in nie dagewesener höhe hilft
verbesserte kurzarbeits regeln greifen
arbeitsplätze können so bewahrt werden
ist also auch im neuen jahr alles corona
nein
und das war es auch im alten nicht nicht
erst seit beginn der pandemie verändert
sich die welt in der wir leben rasant
und grundlegend umso wichtiger ist es
dass deutschland mit all seiner kraft
und seiner kreativität mutige ideen für
die zukunft entwickelt dass unser
wirtschaften unsere mobilität unser
leben klima schont wird dass alle
menschen in deutschland von
gleichwertigen lebensverhältnissen und
echter bildungsgerechtigkeit profitieren
können dass wir uns auch mit europa
besser behaupten in der globalisierten
digitalisierten welt
liebe mitbürgerinnen liebe mitbürger
diese tage und wochen da gibt es nichts
zu beschönigen sind schwere zeiten für
unser land
und so wird es auch noch eine ganze
weile bleiben
es wird noch eine ganze zeit an uns
allen liegen wie wir durch diese
pandemie kommt der winter ist und bleibt
hart wir wissen ja was wir dem virus
entgegensetzen können die neben dem
impfstoff wirksamsten mittel haben wir
selbst in der hand indem wir uns an die
regeln halten jeder und jede von uns wir
alle zusammen
lassen sie mich zum schluss noch etwas
persönliches sagen
in neun monaten ist bundestagswahl zu
der ich ja nicht wieder antreten werde
dies ist deshalb heute aller voraussicht
nach das letzte mal dass ich mich als
bundeskanzlerin mit einer
neujahrsansprache an sie wenden darf ich
denke ich übertreibe nicht wenn ich sage
nie in den letzten 15 jahren haben wir
alle das alte jahr als so schwer
empfunden und nie haben wir trotz aller
sorgen und mancher skepsis mit so viel
hoffnung dem neuen jahr entgegen gesehen
und so wünsche ich ihnen und ihren
familien von herzen gesundheit
zuversicht und gottes segen für das neue
jahr 2021
[Musik]